[Music]
if you want to know what africa wants
go talk to africa go talk to the
africans and africa is not a [ __ ]
it's not a country it's a continent so
it's a very diverse
continent
[Music]
what i would like to see more is really
this kind of concrete partnership
between the eu and the eu and
the african union but also to engage
more startups to give them opportunities
to learn from europe
need to invest more in young people
because if we only look at the
population of africa 60
of the citizens are under 30 years old
they are
you know creating the future
women are always very important
especially in the african
context i mean women have always taken a
lead in terms of
tending to families and i think when
they're
given a leadership roles they tend to
perform a lot better
[Music]
if you first create a bigger dependency
on fossil fuels to then have to
wean yourselves from that is more
difficult than to immediately try and
embrace
new forms of energy
as a result of covet 19 inequalities are
rising everywhere everywhere in the
african continent in europe
within our societies between the
countries
and what we achieved during the last
years in pushing back poverty for
instance is
really at risk
diversity really matters because if
europe learned from
what africa has and africa learned from
what europe has
together they go to a level that's
better than the way they are
individually
[Music]
leaders
there is a need for political
responsibility
of african governments it starts the
future of africa lies in the hands of
africans starting with their leaders who
are
to be held accountable for their actions
both
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
bye